so welcome to the to today's a
conference for today and tomorrow the
conflict in the South China Sea
my name is Eric harms I'm an associate
professor of anthropology and a member
of the Council on Southeast Asian
Studies here at Yale as a Vietnam
specialist I'm especially pleased to be
hosting this conference here because as
so many of you know the conflict in the
South China Sea what the Vietnamese
called the eastern sea being dumb is
currently the most central issue facing
the country you will forgive me for
exercising a bit of Vietnam Oh centrism
I hope but for the rest of my remarks
and throughout the conference
I will refer to the body of water at the
center of our conference as the eastern
sea everyone is free to call it whatever
they would like today and tomorrow but
that is what I will call it we are in
for a series of important contributions
to this topic in the first panel we will
have a series of experts commenting on
the history of the dispute in the
eastern sea where we will learn about
how various maps have been deployed to
argue over sovereignty in the panel
after that we will have papers on the
geopolitics of the sea focusing on why
so many nations want to stake claims to
it and the various machinations they
employ in trying to do so and tomorrow
we will have a series of papers on what
we are calling law fair the use and
abuse of international law to contest
claims in the region throughout these
proceedings we have experts joining us
from around the world among the 14
papers counted 14 being presented
we have guests from the United Kingdom
Germany Canada France Australia the
Philippines and Vietnam as well as
us-based scholars coming from Washington
DC Maine California Boston and Rhode
Island as moderators and discussants we
have members of the Connecticut Vietnam
studies group coming from nearly all the
cardinal points of the Connecticut State
University system with representatives
from Southern Connecticut State Eastern
Connecticut state and Central
Connecticut State our friend from
Western Connecticut State is attending a
cousin's graduation out-of-state we also
have discussants and moderators from
Dartmouth College and new hand
from New York State as well as different
Yale departments across the university
we have some Vietnamese news media
present as well and we are also filming
all of these events which will
ultimately be posted to Yale's YouTube
channel and also made available to
interested new news organizations so
think about that as you're making your
comments and presentations indeed there
has been so much interest in the topic
that we had to have required
registration for seating at the event
given the small size of this room
but I want to stress stress that this is
not an attempt to censor the the form of
discussion in any any way and we look
forward to a very wide diversity of
opinions on the matters at hand is
merely a result of logistical
considerations especially the size of
the room so thank you for your
understanding I have a few of my own
remarks about this topic that I'll make
in just a moment but before I do that I
want to take a moment just to thank all
the many parties who've been involved in
organizing this event first and foremost
is to thank mr. Dunning son who is the
mastermind of this wonderful project
please he's a Fulbright Scholar visiting
us at Yale this semester we've been very
fortunate to benefit from his wisdom in
many presentations and talks and of
course assembling this wonderful group
of people today we also have a support
from mr. Kang John who's in the back was
from the and Hank Gunn should be known
to many of you as a the organizer and
mastermind of the IVC II the Institute
for Vietnamese culture and education and
he's been doing a lot of wonderful
programming about Vietnamese events not
just here but in in many occasions also
a Quan Fubon please stand up Quang who
is
a Vietnamese teacher philosopher
literate literature scholar who's also
been working extremely hard on this
project and most importantly I want to
thank miss Christine música in the back
from the Caliphate Southeast Asian
Studies please stand up Chris Chris took
on this event in addition to all of her
her normal everyday duties which are
quite many and so it's a real testament
to her dedication to the Southeast Asian
Studies program at Yale for all the work
she did an entire las' efforts to make
this happen and I want to thank Michael
Dov as well the chair of the Council of
Southeast Asian Studies for agreeing to
bring this into our year's program so
now bear with me for about 10 minutes or
so I have a few of some comments that
I'd like to make given my background as
an anthropologist who's been working in
Vietnam for close to 20 years the first
time I went to Vietnam was in 1997 and
so given the many approaches to the
topic about to be presented in this
conference which mainly focus on
politics history and law I thought it
might be useful as an anthropologist to
step back and give a sense of how
sensitive this topic is to Vietnamese in
in a more everyday perspective and to
use this as a way to convey some of the
emotions and controversies at hand to do
so I was thinking about how to get how
to start back and I want to step back in
time about two years almost to the same
time of the year two years ago on May
2nd 2014 when China play state-owned oil
rig HD 981 inside Viet Nam's exclusive
economic zone 120 nautical miles off the
coast of Vietnam not far from the
Paracel Islands which along with the
Spratly Islands further south had long
been the focus of sino-vietnamese
maritime disputes as we all know these
waters are claimed by both China and
Vietnam as well as other nations in the
region and Carl Thayer who's with us
today in an article on the topic at the
time accurately remarked at the time
that China's act was quote unexpected
provocative an illegal end quote and
most well-informed international
observers generally agree
with that assessment the placement of
the rig led almost immediately to
protests across Vietnam even the
Vietnamese government which had until
then been extraordinarily cautious in
its dealings with China formally and
forcefully demanded that the rig be
withdrawn a Vietnamese naval flotilla
was deployed to the area but the oil rig
was protected by as many as 80 ships
including seven People's Liberation Army
Navy warships and on May 4th Vietnamese
Coast Guard vessels were sprayed with
cannons and rammed by Chinese ships in
the days that followed the protests in
the streets of Vietnamese cities became
increasingly boisterous and anti-chinese
sentiment in Vietnam became increasingly
volatile by May 12th reports in the
Chinese media claimed that protesters
had directed their anger on the Chinese
embassy in Hanoi and protests were also
growing in cities like Ho Chi Minh City
and Danang as well as other parts of the
country Chinese media at the time tended
to portray these acts as being tacitly
sanctioned by the Vietnamese government
within Vietnam however the tone was
different many Vietnamese bloggers and
everyday citizens were instead insisting
that the leadership in Hanoi was acting
too timid in the face of China in
Vietnam popular anger against China's
action continued to seethe on Tuesday
May 13th rioting broke out in industrial
parks in Binion province near Ho Chi
Minh City and the violence continued
into Wednesday May 14th the violence
itself had followed protests that were
estimated in the range of 20,000 people
mostly workers from the industrial parks
by May 15th
hundreds of Chinese had fled the border
to Cambodia and even more deadly
violence erupted that same day in north
central Vietnam at a Taiwanese steel
mill in the bang boom hang economic zone
in Ha Tinh province where a crowd of
1000 workers killed six Vietnamese and
16 others described as Chinese while the
urban street protests had begun with
expressions of nearly united national
sentiment in protest of the
Chinese actions the tenor of the
discourse shifted when news began to
emerge about the violence against
Chinese people and businesses many
everyday citizens were especially
dismayed to hear that many of the
so-called Chinese people and businesses
being attacked were in many cases
actually Taiwanese Singaporean or even
Korean nationals by Saturday May 17th
Vietnamese officials signaled that
further violence over a dispute with
China would not be tolerated declaring
that over 300 people involved in the
attacks on foreign owned businesses
would be prosecuted the issue was so
important that then Prime Minister and
when Tania conveyed the edict to the
people through a text message
although anti-chinese sentiment remained
and to this day still remains an
important force throughout the general
population all of a sudden the
Vietnamese government realized that it
was facing a confrontation not only with
China but also in some ways that it was
being forced into an uneasy relationship
with its own people I opened this
conference with this reminder about the
events of 2014 for several reasons the
obvious one is to show how volatile this
situation is and to remind us of the
stakes involved those events in 2014
were not isolated that was not the first
time that the geopolitical waters of the
sea have grown rough in the summer of
2009 Chinese navy boats impounded
multiple Vietnamese fishing vessels
leading to similar volatility on the
streets but not the explicit violence
and for the past couple of years we've
been learning of report after report
about new Chinese constructions on the
islands which keep the mood on the
streets quite tense
although most observers like to analyze
the eastern sea issue primarily in terms
of global geopolitics I wish to
emphasize that the issue isn't also
inflected by the complex internal
politics within countries themselves the
question is not just about which country
has sovereignty over the eastern sea but
also how governments in the region
established their own legitimacy with
their own people since around
and seven as bill hatin has written in
his book various incidents have
regularly brought crowds to the streets
of Vietnamese cities and the government
is in the delicate position
of either surfing the crest of that
nationalist wave or being overtaken by
it on the other hand on the one hand the
party state also has the delicate task
of trying to control the unpredictable
human forces that can become unleashed
during moments of extraordinary
ethno-nationalism put simply the problem
of the eastern sea has the potential to
either enhance or threaten the
legitimacy of the Vietnamese government
an optimist might say that this is
actually an opportunity for the
Vietnamese government to reconcile a lot
of interests in the country and to bring
people together it's one of the few
cases for example if you look around at
the audience here today where Vietnamese
Americans and Vietnamese in Vietnam are
united in the interest in this topic and
you can see this as an opportunity for
the Vietnamese government to start
thinking about potential ways to unify
people but a cynic will question whether
the leaders have the political will to
be trustworthy stewards of national
sentiment whatever direction the
Vietnamese government decides to go it
is clear that the Vietnamese people are
watching and the trust of the people
needs to be earned in recent weeks as
China has been continuing with its
constructions of various islands in the
middle of the eastern sea the Vietnamese
people have been concerned about a
different aspect of the sea the ocean
environment and this time they are
directing their anger not to China alone
but also looking internally to what they
perceive as a non-transparent set of
relationships between foreign industries
and Viet Nam's leaders after the recent
discovery of massive fish deaths in the
eastern sea suspicions emerged that the
deaths were caused by a large-scale
dumping of pollution from a steel print
plant owned by Formosa Plastics while
the government has not offered
conclusive connections between the
company and the fish deaths popular
opinion holds it responsible and has
decried the lack of information being
made available the slogan on signs
across the country reads gakuen young
comin back fish need water people need
transparency it's with that call for
transparency in mind that this
conference precedes governments would
their real politic and their sensitive
diplomatic protocols are often forced to
tread lightly or dance around the truth
or to carefully manage what they do or
do not share as academics we have a
different task and that is to lay it all
out on the table and to present the
facts as best we can and it's with that
spirit that I hope to open this
conference thank you so now I'd like to
introduce Michael dub who's the chair of
the Council of Southeast Asian Studies
who also has some opening remarks I'm
quite tall I have problems with low
lecterns so I may just speak from here
with Eric I'd like to welcome you to
this conference thank you for this
opportunity to hear your insights on the
conflict in the South China Sea like
Eric I'm an anthropologist but I work
elsewhere in the region and I thought I
would offer a view of this conflict from
the region some of our panelists will
note the importance of taking an
historical perspective to this conflict
there's a long history in the region of
the transformative impact of
technological innovation in conflict
situations a much storied example were
the 17th century Dutch warships whose
technology of synchronized firing was
without parallel and region and brought
low the powerful naval citadel of
makasar
in 1667 such direct exertions of
military might can overshadow however
more indirect enactments of power which
may have equal if not greater impacts
think of the historic development in the
region of irrigated rice terraces recent
research suggests that rice and
irrigation do not actually greatly
benefit individual households but they
do support the growth of state
structures we might term such
innovations terraforming the the term
originally refers to the process of
transforming a planet into one
sufficiently similar to the earth to
support terrestrial life we could use it
to refer to the process of transforming
an environment like that's the South
China Sea into one more conducive to
state expansion the transformation of
large tracts of land in the region into
export crop plantations during the
colonial era is another such example as
is also the contemporary conversion of
even greater tracts of land to oil palm
plantations such schemes entail shifts
not simply in plant cover but in 10
Uriel rights regimes of knowledge and
political sovereignty but the biggest
impact of terraforming may lie in the
way that it code develops with issues
like those mentioned by professor harms
earlier issues of cultural identity
civilizational ideals and the perceived
arc of history terraforming like the
dredge
in the South China Sea is also history
forming it's an attempt to alter not
just the physical landscape but the
historical landscape and with that I
believe we proceed to photograph